quand on est normalement intelligent on
préfère voir de belles choses plutôt que
vous morpion
plutôt que vaut ce tir you think green
alice nouveau cafard montrez-nous donc
nos belles églises nopopo nos belles
rivières nobel mairie car ces boniments
sec et des bonnes gens
c'est une pas suffisamment les bonnes
gens et n'oubliez plus que la france
c'est le pays de louis xiv et donne la
preuve
monsieur le directeur personnellement je
fais partie du grand nombre de personnes
sans ton contre les shadoks bien sûr
cette émission stupide passe à une heure
où l'on est obligé de la sport elle
oblige
adultes et enfants à la suivre alors
qu'il ne s'adresse à aucun public aux
gens ce voile la face passé nous donc la
place à l'interlude sur la dune
magnifiques paysages de france qui ne
manquent pas en bretagne la bretagne en
auvergne
j'ajoute que je suis étudiante et que je
parle au nom de ma famille monsieur le
directeur de l'ot rtf alors là je
voudrais vous dire tout de suite que il
ya quelque chose que je ne supporte pas
c'est quand vous écrivez que vous disiez
une fille monsieur le directeur de l'ot
et rtf si vous avez 5 minutes à perdre à
la fin du journal ou directeur sportif
si vous écrivez ne dit pas votre fils
elle est dégoûtant passez donc quelques
belles contrées de france il y en a tant
est que la plupart des français ignorent
la lorraine
messieurs les directeurs de l'office ont
dit un office olala supprimés bien vite
c'est shadoks quelle horreur et quel
calvaire va devenir de bruit il y
attarder jolies choses aussi de france
que l'on pourra voir en documenté
l'alsace par exemple
vous n'aurez pas l'alsace et la lorraine
d'autre part est ce que ces demoiselles
qui interroge les uns ou les autres ne
pourraient pas coiffée proprement c'est
pour y voir plus clair je demande que
tous les interludes représentant nos
paysages de france soit annoncée c'est
ainsi que s'il s'agit d'un paysage ou
d'une ville on indique de quoi il s'agit
pour se décontracter passé à l'interlude
faisant admirer des paysages de france
peut être inconnu et que les spectateurs
et pourquoi pas le pays basque en
mécanique ou doute surtout que si on
fait les choses sur les bonnes genre des
bonnes gens du pays basque ont des
bérets et la dernière lettre qui seul
alors évidemment ça démolit tout s'il
vous plaît plus de shadocks c'est
aberrant complètement idiot ma réponse
vaut pour beaucoup de familles de
valence
s'il vous plaît de l'histoire en belles
réalisations modernes françaises en
belle région
les voûtes
genre française beauté française en tout
genre où enfin on dit un d'office
paysages monuments etc etc peut-être les
moutons de panurge irait-il mois à
l'étranger pardonnez moi merci